Willkommen in Bogatepe, einem kleinen Dorf
in über 2000 Metern Höhe
unweit der armenischen Grenze.
Hier ticken die Uhren ein wenig anders
als im Rest der Türkei.
Denn hier haben die Frauen das Sagen –
ob draußen auf dem Feld oder im Stall.
Dahinter steht eine lange Geschichte,
die mit Schweizer Käse begann.
Zümran Ömür,
die Vorsitzende der landwirtschaftlichen
Kooperative von Bogatepe,
erzählt Besuchern im Museum des Dorfes
gern von dem Deutschen Alexander Kaiser –
dem Mann, der vor mehr als hundert Jahren
erkannte,
dass auf diesem Hochplateau mit seinen
saftigen Wiesen ideale Bedingungen
für die Herstellung des berühmten
Emmentalers bestehen.
Dieses Dorf hat Alexander Kaiser
viel zu verdanken,
auch seiner Tochter.
Die hat das Erbe ihres Vaters
fleißig weitergeführt.
Sie haben uns viele Käserezepturen
hinterlassen, die auch ich erst lernen musste.
Ömür und die anderen Frauen
der Kooperative stellen hier
nicht irgendeinen Käse her:
Ihre Spezialität ist der türkische Kars-Gravyer.
Gravyer klingt nicht von ungefähr nach der
Schweizer Käsesorte Gruyere.
Wie es dazu kam, das weiß Ilhan Koculu,
Urenkel des deutschen Pioniers
und heute einer der wenigen Männer,
die in Bogatepe etwas zu sagen haben.
Mein Urgroßvater kam
mit dem Schweizer Freund auf seiner Reise
aus dem Kaukasus hierher,
nach den Wirren
der russischen Oktoberrevolution.
Sie ließen eine Käserei nach
Schweizer Vorbild errichten.
Auch das Gebäude hat er selbst entworfen.
Hier wurde dann zum ersten Mal
der Kars-Gravyer-Käse hergestellt.
Doch später verfiel die Käserei,
das Erbe geriet in Vergessenheit.
Viele Männer des Dorfes zogen
in den 60er- und 70er-Jahren
des vergangenen Jahrhunderts
auf der Suche nach Arbeit weg.
Aber die Frauen besannen sich auf das Erbe
der beiden Käsepioniere.
Zümran Ömür baute die alte Käserei
wieder mit auf.
Und ihr Mann unterstützte sie
ganz selbstverständlich.
Liebling, sagte er, wenn du dir diese Aufgabe
zutraust
und an dich glaubst, dann glaube ich
auch an dich.
Dann stehe ich hinter dir.
Heute ist die 46-Jährige so etwas wie
die Käsebotschafterin des Ortes.
Ihr Mann geht ihr zur Hand –
eine ungewöhnliche Konstellation,
muss er zugeben.
Na ja,
unsere Gesellschaft ist ja schon recht
patriarchalisch geprägt.
Die Männer bestimmen.
Aber hier haben die Frauen meiner Meinung
nach den Platz bekommen,
den sie verdienen.
Die Frauen von Bogatepe haben
ihren Gravyer
zu einem Verkaufsschlager gemacht – als
gäbe es keine türkische Wirtschaftskrise.
Nicht nur im Dorfladen drängeln sich
die Besucher.
Der Käse wird im ganzen Land verkauft
und neuerdings sogar bis nach
Hongkong exportiert.
12.000 Besucher hatten wir allein
im vergangenen Jahr.
Das freut uns,
denn es hilft der Entwicklung unseres Dorfes.
Und es bringt die Frauen hier voran.
Das Beispiel sollte Schule machen auf dem
Land in der Türkei.
Denn die Provinz ist immer noch abgehängt.
Aber das können, wie wir sehen,
Frauen mit kreativen Ideen ändern.
Dann bringt Zümran Ömür
die Besuchergruppe noch zum Bus,
um gleich danach wieder die Kühe hinaus
auf die Weiden zu treiben.
Die Frauen von Bogatepe, so scheint es,
haben nicht nur das Sagen,
sondern auch die ganze Arbeit.